I just had Adam Scott on the show and oh
we talked a little bit about blade mm
blade comic book blade yeah and then I
was reminded by my producers were you in
Blade opus in oh I wish I was in Blade
that the first two movies are fantastic
I am in blade Trinity which is no no
here's what I'll say about blade Trinity
if you watch and and by the way I'm
friends with the writer director and he
agrees with me on this if you just sit
and watch play Trinity it's a d-minus it
just doesn't work but if you know what
they went through to get that movie made
yeah it is an A+ the fact of that movie
exists puts it above Citizen Kane the
fact that they with all the craziness
that went down we were in Vancouver and
Wesley Snipes was going crazy and he
wouldn't come out of his trailer and
you'd walk by his trailer and this wall
of a pot stench would just be like whoa
and of push you to the side and then he
would you he would only answer to the
name blade you you couldn't call him
only answered the blade yeah and after a
while he was ordered to just give he
would communicate with with post-its
that he would give to the director and
each one he would sign blade and and
also you know that it's it's a totally
science fictiony fantasy film because
there's a scene where I play basketball
against a tall black guy and totally
stuff on him so wheat that's the most
unbelievable that's where you're like
vampires could take over cook wait it
did patent your stuff on a 6-3 black
dude when we wrote this crap it is that
BAM so that not every way